the final episode of House of the Dragon
season 1 is about rhaenyra and her
family after the death of her father
King viserys in the previous episode
Alison and the greens crowned aegon as
the new King in King's Landing while
rhaenyra is on the island of Dragonstone
and she doesn't yet know that the greens
stole her throne so what happens and
what does it mean this video has no
spoilers for Hot D past episode 10. the
episode starts with rhaenyra's son Luke
Luke is worried because if Lord Corliss
dies of his fever Luke will inherit
driftmark he'll become the new leader of
house valarion the lord of the tides and
Luke isn't ready for that the valerians
are a sea power with ships and Luke gets
seasick and Luke knows that he's not
really a valerion he's actually the
bastard son of Harwin strong so his
claim to driftmark is illegitimate Luke
says he he doesn't want driftmark he
told callers the same thing years ago
but rhaenyra says that Luke will do his
duty and she'll help him earn his
inheritance because when rhaenyra became
heir to the throne she felt the same
fears and doubts that Luke feels now it
took years of learning and growing
before rhaenyra accepted her
responsibilities so will her children
rise to the challenge like she did
rhaenyra says it's their Destiny to rule
as though their family was always meant
to have the throne and drift Mark but
this season is all about the choices
that created this political situation
viserys chose to make rhaenyra his Heir
and chose to marry alizant and father
aegon rhaenyra chose to have bastard
children with Harwin Alison and Otto
chose to Crown aegon back at the great
Council it was the Lord's choice to
Crown viserys instead of rhaenis and
before that it was the random accidental
deaths of Prince Amon and Balon that
created the whole succession crisis in
the first place the character's choices
and random chants put Rainier's family
in power yet she thinks it's Destiny
part of aegon the conqueror's dream and
that belief could be dangerous viserys
once believed that his son with Emma was
destined to be king and that led to the
tragic deaths of Emma and their baby
there are similar stories with rhaegar
and Daemon blackfyre II and Daenerys in
Game of Thrones these characters blindly
follow their dreams believing they
cannot fail but this ends up destroying
them and the people they love rhaenyra's
belief in Destiny could lead to tragedy
we see rhaenyra's love for Luke which
gives his later death more impact the
warmth Rainier shares with her children
contrasts with Allison's difficult and
distant relationships with her children
rhaenys arrives on Dragonstone last
episode rhaenys escaped aegon's
coronation so now she tells rhaenyra and
Daemon the viserys is dead and aegon has
been crowned daemon's reaction to his
brother's death is to reach for his
sword and say that Alison must have
murdered viserys which is a wild
allegation Daemon saw that viserys was
on his deathbed he was literally falling
apart for years but Daemon wants someone
to blame he needs an enemy to fight
because violence is the only way Daemon
knows how to deal with his feelings like
in episode 3 when he feels insecure so
he beats up that messenger and goes on a
suicide mission against the crab feeder
with viserys dead Daemon again channels
his emotions into violence and prepares
for war against the greens rhaenyra is
also shocked just days ago she seemed to
reconcile with Alison Allison said that
rhaenyra would be Queen but now Alison
betrays her by crowning aegon instead
it's like when Alison suddenly married
viserys rhaenyra feels hurt by a friend
all over again rhaenyra is so upset that
she goes into labor she starts to give
birth even though it's too early the
baby is premature so at this crucial
moment when rhaenyra's claimed to the
throne hangs into balance rhaenyra can't
participate in the politics because
she's busy giving birth rhaenyra's
mother told her that the child bed is
the woman's Battlefield men make war and
ladies make babies and rhaenyra always
hated that she was frustrated being
excluded from politics for being female
and she never wanted to give birth she
saw childbirth kill her mother so in
this childbirth rhaenyra is afraid and
angry the director says rhaenyra is at
war with her own body in the books
rhaenyra is even more Angry here
rhaenyra's labor lasts for three days
and the whole time she screams curses
against aegon aemond and Allison
detailing the torments that she would
inflict upon them before she would let
them die rhaenyra curses the baby inside
her clawing at her own belly shouting
for it to get out when the baby is born
it's dead and deformed in these photos
from a Prosthetics designer the baby has
scaly skin it looks kind of like
grayscale that skin disease that the
crab feeder had grayscale can be
contagious and Daemon got covered in the
crab feeder's blood so you could
speculate that Daemon and rhaenyra's
baby was infected with grayscale but
that's probably not what happened here
because in the books the baby is
described as twisted and malformed with
a stubby scaled tail and this sort of
thing has happened to targaryens before
one of King maegor's wives birthed a
malformed baby with wings Daenerys gives
birth to a stillborn that is scaled like
a lizard with a stubby tail and leather
wings so why do targaryens keep giving
birth to deformed dragon-like babies
targaryens say that they are the blood
of the Dragon their Valyrian ancestors
claimed that they were literally related
to dragons these murals in Hot D show
dragons having sex with humans the books
say that valerians did blood magic
experiments breeding humans with
monsters to create hybrid creatures so
it sounds like targaryens are literally
part Dragon created by Valyrian magic as
a way to control dragons occasionally
birthing dragon-like babies could be a
side effect of their dragon DNA we see
shots of rhaenyra's dragon while she
gives birth emphasizing this Dragon
connection
symbolically dragons represent death and
destruction they are the opposite of
childbirth and New Life the books say
that dragons plant no trees so it makes
sense that the targaryens with their
dragon blood sometimes fail to make new
life through childbirth targaryens are
destructive so can rhaenyra and Daemon
build a peaceful Kingdom or can they
only make fire and blood in the books
rhaenyra names this baby vicenia after
Queen visenya the sister wife of aegon
the Conqueror vicenya used the sword
darksister which is now used by Daemon
and visenya rode the dragon Vega who is
now written by amond in Hot D rhaenyra
wanted to have a sister named visenya so
now she gives that name to her only
daughter who never gets to live in the
book rhaenyra blames the greens for the
death of vasenya she says they stole my
crown and murdered my daughter and they
shall answer for it as she gives birth
rhaenyra screams daemon's name but
instead of supporting his wife Daemon
gathers their allies for war they've
only got a few hundred soldiers on
Dragonstone but some minor Lords from
nearby come to help including Lord Simon
Staunton and Lord bartimus celtegar it's
funny to see Lord celtegar because the
celtagars are Valyrian like the
targaryens and valerians the keldergars
originally came from the ancient
Valyrian dragonlord Empire and survived
the fall of valyria by coming to
Westeros before the Doom so the
celticars have Valyrian silver blonde
hair and they have some cool Treasures
like a Valyrian steel ax and a horn that
can supposedly summon monsters from the
deep but the celticas aren't a powerful
house they don't have dragons like the
targaryens do they don't have ships and
money like the valerions so the celticas
are often ignored throughout this season
viserys and Corliss keep saying that the
targaryens and valerians are the two
great Valyrian houses the last pillars
of old valyria they keep excluding the
celticas which was a running joke in the
hot D Writing Room rhaenyra doesn't want
Daemon to start a war while she's busy
giving birth so instead Daemon confronts
the kingsguard the kingsguard are meant
to be seven noble Warriors sworn to
defend the king but the kingsguard is
now divided between supporting rhaenyra
or aegon Laurent marbrand and Stefan
darklin are with rainyro Kristen Cole
and Eric Cargill are with aegon Eric
Cargill left aegon and is coming to help
Rainier Harold westerling left aegon and
is now missing and there's also a
seventh kingsguard who we haven't seen
yet with all this defection and betrayal
going on Daemon is suspicious of Laurent
and Stefan so to keep them loyal Daemon
threatens them with his dragon and says
if they betray rhaenyra they will die
screaming The Game of Thrones books
often ask if rulers should win their
people's loyalty through fear or through
love the Lannisters often use fear
threats and intimidation while the
Starks cultivate love through honor
respect and good governance Daemon is
more on the side of fear he terrorizes
common folk with his gold cloaks he
tells rhaenyra that your subjects must
fear you and he tells Jace that these
threats to the kingsguard are the true
meaning of loyalty
Otto did a similar thing last episode
forcing Lords to swear loyalty and
hanging Lord Caswell to scare people
into compliance so people on both sides
of this conflict use Fear To Rule Jace
watches closely as his stepdad Daemon
threatens the kingsguard now that Harwin
and Lenor are gone Daemon is the closest
thing Jace has to a father and as
fathers go Daemon Is Not Great earlier
we see Jace pushing Luke around in
training is Daemon a bad influence on
Jace teaching him to be more violent
Jace is rhaenyra's first-born son her
heir to the throne so what kind of man
is Jace becoming rhaenyra and Daemon
cremate their baby it's a similar moment
to Emma and balon's cremation in episode
1 and there's a sense of distance
between Daemon and rhaenyra we see the
two grieving separately not together
they don't always share their feelings
and vulnerability with each other Eric
Cargill arrives because last episode
Eric left aegon to join rhaenyra and on
his way out Eric took viserys's Crown so
while aegon has the crown of aegon the
Conqueror rhaenyra has her father's
Crown which is an important symbol
perhaps suggesting that rhaenyra is
viserys's true Heir this Crown was also
worn by the old King jeharis the
conciliator who brought peace to the
realm can rhaenyra continue that Legacy
Daemon crowns rhaenyra just as he
crowned viserys earlier and this funeral
becomes a coronation from grief to A New
Beginning the scene is very different to
aegon's coronation which was a big
planned event of political theater that
was preceded by secrecy and infighting
while rhaenyra's coronation is
spontaneous and honest and heartfelt
rhaenyra once asked asked if the realm
would accept her as Queen so it's
emotional when all these people kneel to
Queen rhaenyra a showrunner says that in
this moment rhaenyra becomes her father
because she wears her father's crown and
she loses a baby just like viserys lost
baby Balon and lost Emma viserys was
never the same after Emma died will
rhaenyra's reign also be defined by loss
queen rhaenyra holds her first council
at the painted table this is the table
where aegon the Conqueror planned his
conquest and where Stannis and Daenerys
plan their attacks the table is now lit
up from within like a RGB gamer keyboard
the pieces are set to play The Game of
Thrones in the books this meeting is
called the black Council because
rhaenyra's side is called the blacks and
aegon side is called the greens the
title of this air episode is the black
queen which evokes chess which is
another Game of Thrones most of this
show so far happened in the red keep in
King's Landing it was focused on one
family in one place but this map table
reminds us that there's a whole world
out there and now that the throne is at
stake the whole realm is in play from
Winterfell to Dawn so the blacks figure
out who are their allies and who are
their enemies they already have the
support of houses celtigar Staunton
darklin Massey and bar Emin but those
are all minor houses in the crownlands
the area around King's Landing they'll
also need help from more powerful houses
like the Starks tullys and Aarons the
Starks of Winterfell rule the North like
Ned Stark in Game of Thrones in hot day
episode 1 Lord rickonstark swore to
support rhaenyra rickon is dead now and
the new Lord is his on craigenstock the
blacks figure that the Starks are
honorable so Craigen will keep rickon's
oath and will support rhaenyra though in
the books they say that the north is so
far away from the rest of Westeros that
by the time a northern Army marches
South the war might be over already the
veil is ruled by house Aaron of the
Eerie like Lysa Aaron in Thrones the
current ruler is Jane Aaron and rhaenyra
says that Jane will support her because
rhaenyra's mother was an Aaron a cousin
of Lady Jane though previously Daemon
said that he would ask Lady Jane to give
him the castle of runestone and that
didn't work out in the books Jane warns
Daemon that he's not welcome in the veil
so will Jane support the blacks the
riverlands are ruled by the tullys of
riverrun like edmure Italy in Thrones
the current Lord is Grover Tully but
Grover is old and we heard previously
that grow over his son mostly rules for
him and rhaenyra says that Grover is
fickle so she plans to send Daemon on
his Dragon to convince the tullys to
support them the riverlands are in the
center of Westeros near King's Landing
so the region is strategically important
Daemon suggests that they take the
castle of harrenhal as a place to gather
their forces the stormlands are ruled by
the baratheons of Storm's end like Renly
Baratheon in Thrones in episode 1 Lord
boromand Baratheon swore to support
rhaenyra and borrowment was friendly
with his cousin rhaenys but boromand has
now died and his son boros rules the
stormlands the blacks hope that boros
will stay loyal like his father Dawn is
ruled by Prince Coran Martell at this
time Dawn is not a part of Westeros they
don't recognize the authority of the
iron throne and Dawn has occasionally
gone to war against the targaryens so
the martells not a likely Ally for
rhaenyra or aegon the reach is ruled by
the tyrells of highgarden like Mace
Tyrell and Elena in Game of Thrones
currently the Lord of highgarden is a
baby named Lionel with his mother acting
as radiant in the books the blacks
expect the tyrells to support aegon and
the hightowers technically the tyrells
rule over the hightowers but in many
ways the hightowers are more powerful
than their Tyrell overlords because the
hightowers rule Old Town the biggest
city in Westeros and they're closely
tied with the faith of the seven and the
maesters of the Citadel Lord Hobart
Hightower and his brother Otto are the
main supporters of aegon's claim so the
tyrells and the reach may follow their
lead the westerlands are ruled by the
Lannisters of casterly rock like Tywin
Lannister in Thrones The Lord of
casterly rock is now Jason Lannister and
he will probably support aegon because
Jason twin brother Thailand is on
aegon's small Council Jason is probably
still butt hurt that rhaenyra rejected
his marriage proposal and we've seen
Jason close with the hightowers the
Lannisters are rich and Powerful they
command the westerlands and they have
ships so they'll be an important Ally
for the greens the iron islands are
ruled by house Greyjoy of Pike like
Balon Greyjoy in Thrones The Lord of
Pike is currently Dalton Greyjoy called
the red Kraken for all the blood he
spilled in battle Dalton is only 16
years old and he's already sailed and
raided around the world Dalton has a
Valyrian steel sword called Nightfall
and it said he loves three things the
sea his sword and women the greyjoys are
important because they have a powerful
Fleet that could rival the valerions but
the ironborn don't have the best
reputation for being reliable allies so
will they support rhaenyra or aegon
another important house is House
valerion of driftmark led by Lord
Corliss technically the valerions are a
minor House of the crownlands sworn to
House Targaryen but in practice the
valerions are one of the most powerful
houses with the biggest Fleet and the
most money so rhaenyra hopes for their
support so the blacks are outnumbered
aegon and the hightowers have more
soldiers than Rainier does aegon has the
capital city of King's Landing he has
the throne he has the conqueror's crown
and The conqueror's Sword and the
conqueror's name he was anointed by a
septon in front of tens of thousands of
people and many lords will prefer aegon
because he's male rhaenyra had once been
popular she was called the realm's
Delight but the books say that
rhaenyra's body is now aged and
thickened so she might not be as popular
anymore many law Lords swore Oaths to
support rhaenyra but that was 24 years
ago and many of those Lords are now dead
so will rhaenyra get their allies she
needs to defeat the greens Lord celtegar
says it doesn't matter who supports them
because rhaenyra has lots of dragons the
most powerful weapons of war in This
World rhaenyra rides the dragon Cyrax
Daemon has caraxis rhaenys has melis
Baylor has Moon Dancer Jace has Vermax
Luke has arax Joffrey has tyraxes
rhaenyra and daemon's son aegon has a
dragon called stormcloud though aegon is
too young to fly so the blacks have
seven Dragon Riders while the greens
only have four aegon rides Sunfire amond
rides Vega Helena rides dream fire and
there is a fourth child of Alison and
viserys named davron daeron is currently
chilling in Old Town with the high
Towers but daeron has a Dragon named
tessarion the blue Queen aegon and
Helena's children johera and joheras
have young dragons called morgul and
shrikos but they're too young for war so
the blacks have more Dragon Riders than
the greens do and the blacks have some
unclaimed dragons who don't yet have
Riders sea smoke was the dragon of Lenor
and is now on driftmark Verma Thor and
Silverwing were the dragons of the old
king jahiris and queen alisane and there
are the wild dragons sheep stealer Gray
Ghost and the cannibal sheep stealer is
an ugly Brown Dragon who eats sheep from
Shepherd's flocks along with the
occasional sheepdog gray ghost is shy
and Elusive eating fish snatched from
the sea and the cannibal is a big old
Dragon notorious for eating other
dragons even raiding hatcheries to eat
dragon hatchlings and eggs some say that
the cannibal was on Dragonstone before
the target Aryans arrived if the blacks
can find riders for these unclaimed
dragons they could outnumber the Green's
Dragon Riders 13-4 and sure the greens
will still have a bigger Army but the
history of aegon's Conquest shows that
almost always dragons beat armies
however dragons can kill dragons like
King maegor the cruel once used his
Dragon ballerion to kill his nephew
aegon and his Dragon Quicksilver and the
greens do have Vega the most powerful
dangerous Dragon alive so if rhaenyra
sends her Dragon Riders against aegon's
Dragon Riders she'd have to risk the
lives of her family rhaenyra hopes to
find a peaceful solution instead
Otto arrives with a message from Alison
and aegon and he uses a banner with a
green dragon the Targaryen sigil is
usually a red dragon but ifrainira and
aegon used the same color heraldry the
this conflict could be very confusing so
to tell the sides apart in the books
rhaenyra uses a Targaryen Dragon
quartered with her mother's Aaron sigil
and with the valerion's seahorse while
aegon uses a golden dragon because his
Dragon Sunfire is colored golden he also
used a golden dragon at his coronation
last episode although now Otto is using
a green dragon so maybe the greens are
still figuring out their new logo But
Otto meets Daemon on the Dragonstone
bridge and rhaenyra arrives on Cyrax
just like the scene in episode 2. Back
Then Daemon was rebelling and rhaenyra
made him back down but this time
rhaenyra and Daemon are united it seems
like a bad idea to send Otto on this
diplomatic Mission since rhaenyra and
Daemon hate Otto they've been political
Rivals for years just last episode Otto
wanted to murder rhaenyra until Alison
forced him to offer peace instead so why
why does Allison trust Otto with this
peace Mission maybe Alison should have
come herself in the books it's Grand
maester Orwell who brings this piece off
her rhaenyra says all while is wrong to
support aegon so she rips off his
maester's chain and gives the chain to
her maester gerardus declaring gerardus
to be the real grand maester mushroom
claims that Orwell is so scared by this
that he pisses himself But Otto gives
his peace terms he says that if rhaenyra
gives up her crown and lets aegon be
king then they'll let rhaenyra live as
the ruler of Dragonstone and Luke can
inherit driftmark her younger sons aegon
and viserys will go to live in King's
Landing and what this really means is
that the kids will be hostages like
ifrinero Rebels aegon and viserys could
be killed it's like how Theon was taken
to live with the Starks after the
Greyjoy Rebellion
Otto says rhaenyra can't win he urges
rhaenyra to make peace and he gives
Rainier a page from a book in episode 1
rhaenyra gave this page to Alison it's a
symbol of their friendship of the hope
that they might reconcile but this page
could also have other meanings because
the page describes nymeria an ancient
Eastern princess rhaenyra Once listened
to a song about how nymeria sailed away
to escape her enemies like how Kristen
Cole said that he and rhaenyra should
flee to the East and like Alison
suggested last episode that rhaenyra
should leave Westeros so maybe running
away is an option on the other hand
nymeria is a symbol of female power and
Defiance nymeria became a ruler in Dawn
so the page highlights rhaenyra's
difficult choices here should she run
away should she stay and fight or should
she try to compromise rhaenyra's actor
says that on some level rhaenyra wants
validation from Otto rhaenyra has just
lost her father and so she seeks
approval from Otto as a male authority
figure part of her is tempted to submit
and seek acceptance from Otto and Alison
so rhaenyra has a lot of complex
emotions here meanwhile Daemon threatens
to cut off Otto's dick Daemon is not the
best Diplomat but rhaenyra keeps the
pace and considers Otto's offer the
meeting also brings together the two
kingsguard Eric and Eric after Eric
abandoned arik and joined rhaenyra these
twin brothers are now on opposite sides
of this conflict in the books there's a
sad song written about this meeting
called Farewell My Brother supposedly
Eric and Eric tried to convince each
other to change sides and when that
failed they made Declarations of love
and parted knowing that next time they
meet they would be enemies Daemon and
the Lords are Keen to attack the greens
with dragon but rhaenyra knows that when
dragons go to war Everything Burns and
there's collateral damage like all those
innocent people raining skilled with her
dragon dragons are weapons of
indiscriminate mass destruction and if
Rainier uses them against King's Landing
many innocent people could die rhaenyra
doesn't want to rule a kingdom of Ash
and Bone Daenerys faces this same
problem in Game of Thrones and
ultimately she decides to just burn
King's Landing anyway will rhaenyra find
a better solution and succeed where
Daenerys fails Daemon loudly questions
rhaenyra undermining her Authority in
front of their allies so privately
rhaenyra tells Daemon that they have a
higher purpose viserys told rhaenyra
about aegon the conqueror's dream the
prophecy that the targaryens must unite
Westeros to defeat the white walkers but
terrainira's surprise Daemon doesn't
know this prophecy the secret is passed
down from King to Heir and viserys never
considered Daemon his Heir he'd never
fully trusted him Daemon often felt
rejected by viserys so it hurts him
deeply to find out about this secret
about another way the viserys chose
rhaenyra and not him rhaenyra's actor
says that Daemon gets shafted from
Beyond the Grave by the person he most
loves so once again Daemon expresses his
emotions with violence and Daemon chokes
rhaenyra rhaenyra's actor suggests that
Daemon has never been violent to
rhaenyra before maybe Rainier or thought
Daemon would never hurt her because
she's his love the mother of his
children but no Daemon is dangerous even
to his own wife he killed his previous
wife with a rock after all so is
rhaenyra safe with her husband what
might Daemon do next time he's emotional
for the last six years Corliss valerion
was fighting on the stepstones he got
wounded in a battle and it looked like
he might die which sparked that whole
succession crisis when his brother
vemond tried to claim driftmark but now
Carlos has survived and returned to his
wife rhaenys rhaenys accuses Corliss of
abandoning her they had just lost both
of their children Lana and laner rhaenys
needed her husband's support but he left
her for his War rhaenys tells callers
that vemond was killed for his power
grab and cola says that the valerians
have a problem with Reckless ambition
like corliss's endless ambition led him
to travel the world and make his family
rich but he went too far in his attempts
to get his family on the Iron Throne he
pushed for rhaenys to be Queen he tried
to marry his daughter Lena to King
viserys he married his son Lenor to
princess rhaenyra and because of these
Ambitions Carlos's family was destroyed
Elena is dead lane or is seemingly dead
vemond is dead and Corliss himself
nearly died so caller says that rhaenys
was right all along his endless ambition
is destructive he says he'll give it up
and retire to driftmark to be with
rhaenys and his granddaughters Baylor
and Rayna but Rainey says it's too late
for that now their supposed grandsons
Jace Luke and Joff are in line to the
throne Luke is heir to driftmark and
Baylor and Rayna are betrothed to marry
Jace and Luke the valerians are tied to
Rainier and now so as long as aegon has
the throne their family is in danger
throughout this episode rhaenys watches
Rainier judges her she sees that
rhaenyra truly wants peace and unity she
believes that rhaenyra didn't kill Lena
so Rainey says they should support
Rainier and this time callus lessons he
announces that the valerians will fully
support rhaenyra in the books Corliss is
in his 70s and he's weakened by his
favor he says he's clinging to life like
a drowning sailor clinging to wreckage
but mayhaps the gods have preserved him
for one last fight with the valerion's
wealth and ships they'll be a powerful
Ally for rhaenyra and kolas reveals that
he now has control of the stepstones on
the narrow sea last time he and Daemon
took over the stepstones they didn't
fortify or defend them afterwards so the
triarchy just took them back but this
time Corliss left a Garrison to hold the
stepstones rhaeniram suggested doing
that in a previous episode so now the
valerions will blockade the gullet which
is the Ocean between King's Landing and
the narrow Sea by controlling the
traffic of ships they can prevent the
greens from getting supplies by sea so
rhaenyra plans to surround King's
Landing with soldiers and ships to force
aegon to surrender but they don't yet
have enough men so rhaenyra wants help
from the Stark's Aarons and baratheons
the quickest way to convince these
houses to join her is with Dragons
saranya sends her sons Jace and Luke as
Messengers on Dragon back this shot of
the kids above the painted table shows
us that Jace and Luke and Baylor and
Reina are no longer just children they
are military assets pieces in the Game
of Thrones in the books the younger son
Joffrey wants to go to but rhaenyra
doesn't let him because he's just 11.
the boys are Keen to show off their
dragon riding to prove that they are not
just strong bastards they are true
targaryens because only targaryens can
ride dragons Corliss corrects the boys
and tells them they are valerians but he
says this with pride in his voice the
plan is that Jace will fly to the veil
to talk with Lady Jane Aaron then he'll
go to Winterfell to talk with Lord Craig
and Stark Kragen is Young 21 in the
books so rhaenyra hopes that Jace will
make friends with this important Ally
meanwhile Luke the younger son will have
the quicker easier task to fly to
Storm's end to talk with Lord boros
Baratheon all of these families once
swore loyalty to Rainier Aaron and
Baratheon are related to rhaenyra and
dragons are very convincing in the books
King jahiris believed that dragons are
best used as an unspoken threat a dragon
is a reminder of all the battles where
armies have been roasted in dragonflame
so just showing a dragon to a lord can
convince them to stay loyal like a kind
of nuclear deterrence sarinira hopes
that her sons and their dragons will
quickly convince the North Trail and
stormlands to support her she doesn't
want Jace and Luke to get in any fights
this is a strictly diplomatic Mission so
she makes them swear on the
seven-pointed star the holy book of the
faith of the seven rhaenyra doesn't
believe in the seven the targaryens are
from valyria not Westeros and targaryens
tend to see themselves as Gods but King
aegon Targaryen The Conqueror realized
that to rule Westeros the targaryens
need to respect westerosi culture and
religion Daenerys learns something
similar when she tries to rule Maureen
she is told that if you want to be king
of the rabbits You've Gotta Wear some
floppy ears so Daenerys wears
traditional miranese clothing when in
Marine so telling Jace and Luke to
respect the seven gods is a good
political lesson from rhaenyra though
she makes a mistake sending her children
on this Mission Jace and Luke are
teenagers with little experience in
politics they they have a history of
getting involved in impulsive fights
Jace and Luke of rhaenyra's heirs making
them potentially valuable hostages if
captured and their young dragons are not
as impressive as fully grown dragons it
might have been smarter to send rhaenys
on melis or Daemon on karaxis for these
missions but rhaenyra farewells her sons
and sees Luke for the last time
Daemon visits a dragon this is Verma
Thor the bronze Fury who was once the
dragon of the Old King jahiris Verma
Thor and jeheris flew all over Westeros
on Royal tours alongside Queen alisane
on Silverwing Verma Thor fought in
dornish Wars burning a Martell Fleet
then Jairus died and for 30 years now
Verma Thor hasn't had a rider Verma Thor
is the second oldest and probably second
biggest dragon alive after vegar so he
could be the most powerful weapon
rhaenyra has if someone can claim Verma
Thor and ride him only people with
Targaryen blood can ride dragons and a
Targaryen can only ride one Dragon
Rayner Targaryen doesn't have a dragon
yet so maybe she will claim firmathor
Daemon sings of Valyrian lullaby to
soothe Verma Thor but he still appears
wild and ferocious this is the dangerous
power that war could unleash and Daemon
is eager to use it Luke and arax arrive
at Storm's end the Baratheon Castle this
is one of the strongest castles in
Westeros with massive walls and a
colossal tower that looks like a fist
raised to the sky the castle was
supposedly built by Duran God's grief in
defiance of the storm Gods Melisandre
says there are protective spells woven
into its Stones Luke discovers that the
greens got here first to treat with Lord
boros they sent amond the guy whose eye
Luke caught out years ago and boros is
siding with amond rhaenyra had assumed
that boros would be like his father
boromand the book says boromand was
Stone Strong and unmoving but boros is
like the wind that rages and howl and
changes boros doesn't keep his father's
oath to support rhaenyra he doesn't care
that rhaenys is his distant cousin he
feels that rhaenyra has taken him for
granted and he would prefer the male
ruler aegon to the female ruler rhaenyra
so boros accepts amon's offer of a
marriage pact aemond will marry one of
boros's daughters in return for an
alliance it's like when Rob Stark was
going to marry a Fray in Game of Thrones
in the books mushroom claims that amond
kisses each of the Baratheon women
before he chooses one to marry boros
asks if Luke can also offer a marriage
Alliance but Luke is not free to marry
because he is betrothed to Rayna so
boros rejects Luke and rhaenyra and
sides with the greens we see that boros
can't read so he gets his maester to
read Rainier's letter for him it's
pretty common in Westeros for Lords to
be illiterate and to rely on maesters
and and there are hints in the books
that maesters sometimes twist the words
of letters manipulating Lords for their
own goals aemond takes off his eye patch
to show the sapphire that he wears in
his empty eye socket amond wants payback
for when Luke cut out his eye so he
demands that Luke cut out one of his own
eyes to pay this debt boros prevents
them from fighting because he doesn't
want princes mutilating each other in
his living room and amond does a little
twirl she think his knife just like the
little twill he did years earlier so
Luke tries to get out of Dodge while
he's still got his eyeballs but amond
and vegar chase after him and in the
books there's a little more to this
because at first aemond doesn't Chase
Luke but then one of boros's daughters
Maris speaks up Maris is angry that
amond didn't choose her to marry so
Maris says was it one of your eyes Luke
took or one of your balls she taunts
aemond makes him angry and it's because
of that that aemon decides to chase
after Luke amond and vegar swoop and
snap at Luke and arax amond doesn't
intend to kill Luke he just wants to
scare him he enjoys terrorizing the kid
who took his eye but things get out of
control arax spits flame in Vega's face
even though Luke didn't tell arax to do
that then Veigar chases them down and
kills Luke and arax even though amond
didn't tell vagar to do that the dragons
disobey their Riders and now rhaenyra's
son Prince Luke is dead we saw in the
dragon pit that controlling a dragon is
a skill and a bond that develops over
time we saw vegar resist Lena's command
to burn her dragons have a will of their
own in the books Daenerys struggles to
control her Dragon drogon she thinks
that the ancient valyrians used magic
spells and horns to control dragons but
the targaryens don't have those tools in
episode 1 visera said the idea that we
controlled the dragons is an illusion
cause dragons are fire dragons are magic
and the books say that magic can't be
controlled it's a sword without a hilt
viserys warned that dragons could
destroy the targaryens just as the
valyrians were doomed it's hinted that
dragons can feel the emotions of their
Riders and In This Moment Luke and amond
are full of emotion of adrenaline and
fear so it's no surprise that the
dragons felt that and lashed out with
violence or maybe the dragons acted out
of their own desires Veigar is a 180
year old battle-hardened nuclear
dinosaur maybe she doesn't care what the
teenager on her back wants ultimately it
may have been a bad idea to give dragons
to children in a political crisis and
with the death of Prince Luke peace
seems impossible and what does this mean
for aemond Luke was amon's nephew and in
Westeros kinslaying killing family is a
terrible crime will aemond admit that he
killed Luke by accident or will he
accept the label of kin Slayer on
Dragonstone rhaenyra finds out that her
son has been killed the actor says that
rhaenyra thought she knew grief she had
lost her mother Emma and her father
viserys she lost her lover Harwin she
lost her baby vicenia but now that she's
lost her son Luke she realizes she knew
nothing of how deep grief can be this
loss changes rhaenyra will she still
want peace or will she want to punish
the green for killing her son the script
says war is in her eyes this look is
similar to daenerys's expression in Game
of Thrones before she Burns King's
Landing will rhaenyra do the same will
she unleash her dragons and Daemon
against her enemies season 1 is kind of
the prologue to the main conflict of
House of the Dragon season 1 tells us
the backstory who these families are
what's their relationships and history
that's why it has all these time jumps
and actor changes it shows a storm
brewing over Generations but season two
will be different season 2 is when the
storm breaks and the dance of the
Dragons begins
if you want to know the full story of
hot day you've got to check out the book
Fire and Blood there's also the main
series of Game of Thrones books and the
world book and Duncan egg you can get
any one of these on audiobook for free
right now at audible.com ASX sign up for
a Premium Plus trial membership and you
get an audiobook to keep even if you
cancel the trial you can get any Game of
Thrones book or Lord of the Rings or
Dune membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audiobooks and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com ASX or text ASX to 500
500. thanks for watching and thanks to
the patrons including Jade Harris Eva
damn it Mike Micah Joel love Alex Kaplan
Scott Tony rygin Lane and Carnage
Trooper cheers
I'm not signing [ __ ] until I get nigh
you owe me we're not giving you an eye
you realize how Preposterous that is